procès de trois l'autodéfense en
question le bol est accusé par le
relativement le 24 mai italie le 25
avril le plus triste pour la démocratie
le secrétaire général de l'onu s'adresse
directement aux brigades rouges georges
séguy et la cgt à matignon pas
d'illusions mais j'ai une volonté
d'exploiter toutes les possibilités de
négociation parti communiste va
contestation encore plus vive à la
veille du comité central mais là
messieurs bonsoir c'est un procès qui
passionne toute la france là se passer
aujourd'hui à trois sur le banc des
accusés un homme propriétaire d'une
résidence secondaire dans leurs robes
là bas les villas isolées sont souvent
visités comme on dit mais quand cela
vous arrive pour la douzième fois 12
fois pour un seul homme
on peut faire des bêtises et c'est ce
qui est arrivé à monsieur le gras et la
faire vous allez le voir s'est très mal
terminée aussi bien pour lui que pour
ses cambrioleurs martin laroche joubert
va vous raconter son histoire sachez
tout de même que le jugement est mis en
délibéré dans un mois tout juste
mais s'il faut en croire la population
de la région c'est tout vu personne
attelions personnes de soutenir le
voleur lionel le bras avait bâti sa
résidence secondaire de ses propres
mains il avait habillé de ses rêves
d'adolescent admirateur de kit carson et
autres buffalo bills les routes chariot
un choral une tête de vache et un nom
texas city qui fleure plus la prairie
des états unis que les bosquets de
l'aube
mais les mauvais garçons avaient
cambriolé deux fois le ranch
excédé le propriétaire de texas city
avait tendu un piège à transistor bourré
de poudre attendait le cambrioleur
prévenant le garagiste avait planté un
panneau piège à feu les à jour de
bûcheron s'introduisent dans le ranch
las et blessé l'autre tué l'un d'eux je
prends les blessés puis pouvoir les
trouver
tu puisse aller voir un lecteur ou place
montré contre
est ce que vous le regretter aujourd'hui
d'avoir fabriqué ces explosifs et il
savait à quoi s'en tenir quand même
aujourd'hui lionel le gras est inculpé
de blessure et d'homicide involontaire
le voleur survivants lui réclame des
dommages et intérêts alors à villenauxe
la colère gronde villenauxe un village
de commerçants un village l'on retourne
à l'heure de la retraite un village
entouré de résidences secondaires
éloignées des grandes villes où chacun
cultive son jardin à l'abri des clôtures
et où comme partout
personne n'aime voir piétiner ses
plates-bandes des tracts des affiches
fleurissent dans les vitrines des
commerçants on accusa justice d'être
trop clémente envers les voleurs trop
sévère envers les honnêtes citoyens
maintenant traduit devant les tribunaux
un comité de soutien se forment une
campagne de signatures sur 1840
habitants plus d'un millier en faveur du
garagiste et de sa justice expéditive
lionel le gracie rendu à son procès avec
la majorité du village derrière lui et
des lettres de deux kits part nous
pensons que si cette hormone est fait
coin d'année alors ne l'avons plus qu'à
laisser la porte ouverte est bien un
écriteau à l'entrée messieurs les
voleurs en traits et servez vous vous
voyez confier à j 6 ou même convaincu
sir d'abord j'ai été signé à la mairie
eh oui
donc s'il a bien suivi la région pour
leur faire peur hein faut faire quelque
chose si on ne se défend pas qui c'est
qui va nous défendre
à l'heure actuelle on se demande s'ils
ont deux posters de six semaines parce
qu'on trouve que la justice n'est pas
assez sévère
c'est devient de pire en pire j'avais
lui l'a fait s'ils avouent le faire de
matic mans mais je crois je ferais
pareil quand sûr
ceux qui n'ont pas signé se taisent ils
n'ont pas signé pour ne pas peser sur le
jugement ou bien parce qu'ils sont pour
la justice et non pour les justiciers
devant la caméra ils refuseront de
parler même le curé l'homme de la
tolérance et de la charité a refusé de
se prononcer cela leur porterait du tort
distille tous on risquerait peut-être de
les assimiler à des voyous le procès du
garagiste prend à tour national avec
l'entrée en scène de l'association
légitime défense qui demandent moins de
sollicitude pour les criminels et défend
le droit à la propriété s'agit pas de
tirer à l'extérieur sur quelqu'un mais
chez soi ce qu'il est à moi est à moi
même si j'ai un stylo c'est un mois je
les gagne et on me le faire j'y tiens et
je veux pas qu'on me le prenne donc si
je suis chez moi ce stylo de défendre et
je le dis bien par n'importe quel moyen
chez moi et même si justement
cambrioleurs moi je verrais aucun
inconvénient de tuer chez moi
certes il y a d'un côté la défense du
droit de propriété qui ne risque pas
d'être remises en question mais les
juges de 3 mettront dans l'autre plateau
de la balance
le principe essentiel que nul ne doit se
faire justice lui même
oui tout ça en effet n'est pas si simple
et on peut se demander dans quelle
mesure on l'autorisé des gens à se faire
justice eux mêmes oui il est très
significatif patrick que martine
laroche-joubert n'ai pas pu enregistrer
films et ceux des habitants de troie qui
considère que le principe de la vie
d'une défense ne s'applique pas
systématiquement et surtout n'importe
comment
en somme ces gens là haut tu peur de la
peur des autres bien sûr monsieur
legrand n'est pas un criminel au sens
courant du mot bien sûr il ya des
limites à la patience et l'injustice
c'est sûr que l'asus la police est très
souvent débordé faute de moyens que la
justice est lente faute de crédits et
surtout que les magistrats prennent
parfois les décisions qui vont à
contre-courant de ce que réagi la
majorité des français c'est une
responsabilité qui leur coûte cher ne
serait-ce que l'estiment du plus grand
nombre
les voyous les criminels doivent être
punis la justice doit être sévère
efficace mais surtout rentable c'est à
dire qu'elle doit d'abord punir ensuite
dissuadé de récidiver son rôle véritable
le plus difficile c'est à dire aussi
qu'elle doit donner aux citoyens c'est
que par son action de la sécurité et du
respect de son bon droit
reste qu'on a mis des siècles à sortir
et à grand peine de la justice
personnelle qu'on appelle vengeance et
des milices privées qui deviennent
forcément peu à peu le droit du plus
fort depuis nombreux et de plus rapide
monsieur legras n'aurait jamais dû à un
homme s'il y avait suffisamment de
gendarmes et de policiers à 3 pour
protéger son bien mais ce qu'ils
applaudissent aujourd'hui penseront est
sans doute tout autre chose si à la
place des voleurs étaient entrés en
fracturant la la porte en son absence et
avait subi le même sort quelqu'un
d'autre par exemple un pompier ou un
voyageur égaré sous la neige c'est
demain que le conseil des ministres doit
trancher pour savoir quelle hausse
appliquée au tarif public des hausses
qui seront très rapide car elle pourrait
rentrer en vigueur dès mardi prochain
donc le 2 mai rien n'est officiel mais
on pense que les paris brouillage heures
de la sncf pourrait augmenter de 15 %
ceux de l'edf gdf de 10% même chose ou
un peu moins pour le charbon domestique
toujours dans le domaine du
vraisemblable les timbres-poste
passerait de 1 franc 1 120 et le ticket
de métro de bus de 1 franc 10 à 1 franc
il semble que pour les transports la
note étant assez lourde à payer pour
l'usager est bien là au sort a lieu en
juin et nous en mai mais tout cela je
vous le répète demande être vérifié je
nous ai donné que ces indications
rassemblés par notre service économique
ce que tout cela vous intéresse tous
bien sûr mais la réponse définitive
demain donc appel conseil des ministres
point final aux premières consultations
du premier ministre qui a rencontré tous
les partenaires sociaux c'est-à-dire
syndicalistes ouvriers cadres ou patrons
derniers visiteurs de raymond barre
georges séguy pour la cgt georges séguy
dans le dialogue avec le premier
ministre n'a pas été apparemment de la
même nature que celui de monsieur m en
mer
à la différence des organisations
syndicales qui ont été reçus avant le 19
mars par le premier ministre et nous
n'avons pas répondu à son invitation
faut connaître ses intentions en matière
sociale le fisc lui aussi bien son
discours de politique générale à
l'assemblée nationale nous avait par
avance donner une idée de sa politique
pour l'essentiel la même qu'avant rester
les élections austérité pour les
travailleurs privilèges dont les gros
possédants acceptation des exigences du
patronat notamment en ce qui concerne la
liberté des prix nous sommes donc venus
sans illusion mais avec la volonté
d'explorer sérieusement toutes les
possibilités de négociation susceptible
d'aboutir à des résultats positifs ou
les travailleurs étant entendu qu'on a
envie or le vide ici parce que nos
trains ferries ne se concentre pas sur
de simple problème de procédure
mais sur le contenu concret de ces
négociations
après ce dernier entretien du premier
ministre les syndicats évidemment une
double question qui doit être posée quel
sera le calendrier des négociations et
sur quoi porteront thème pour le secteur
public c'est en principe demain matin en
conseil des ministres que devront être
fixés et annoncer les dates d'ouverture
des négociations
elles s'ouvriront par une reprise des
discussions salariales dans la fonction
publique le secteur privé c'est la
semaine prochaine que le patronat on se
fera séparément les différentes
organisations syndicales alors reste à
définir sur quoi porteront ces
négociations elles devront bien sûr
s'inscrire dans le cadre des mesures
présentées la semaine dernière au
parlement par le premier ministre mesure
qui impose une double contrainte le
simple maintien du pouvoir d'achat et le
blocage des charges salariales ça donc
pour l'essentiel sur la revalorisation
des bas salaires et la revalorisation
des rémunérations des travailleurs
manuels comporteront
entretien pour l'emploi la décision
annoncée par le premier ministre de ne
plus soutenir à tout prix les secteurs
retardataires passablement créé une
situation difficile et de ce fait et
négociations seront limitées pour
l'essentiel on parlera de la durée du
travail et des conditions du travail
enfin un point d'interrogation dans ce
climat de détente et de dialogue
après sa polémique avec la cfdt et après
le recul quel enregistrés lors des
dernières élections professionnelles la
cgt se retrouve un peu isolé et il est
très vraisemblable que d'ici peu la cgt
soit amené à repasser à l'offensive
la politique maintenant à la veille de
l'ouverture d'un rendez vous politique
très important le comité central du
parti communiste
une véritable petite bombe qui vient de
l'exploser c'est une bande qui a fait
exploser le philosophe communiste louis
althusser dans une série de trois
articles dont le second est paru
aujourd'hui dans le monde
louis althusser attaque très durement la
direction du pc plus durement kokal
communiste juste alors à tel point que
le socialiste claude estier disait ce
matin sur france inter que ces analyses
aller plus loin encore que celle du ps
les noëls copains nous allons essayer de
détailler la nature des critiques du
philosophe et je vous propose d'ores et
déjà de voir en images la façon dont
fonctionnent les mécanismes internes du
parti
ce que l'on appelle le centralisme
démocratique et qui est aujourd'hui
notamment par monsieur althusser très
contesté à la base de l'organisation du
parti communiste les cellules il y en a
25 mille la section est un groupe de
cellules dans une ville un quartier où
une grande entreprise dans chaque
département il y à une fédération tous
les trois ans réunit le congrès il est
composé de délégués des fédérations le
congrès élit le comité central
le comité centrale élit le bureau
politique et le secrétariat
l'organisation du parti communiste
ressemble donc à une pyramide la vie de
cette pyramide repose sur un principe le
centralisme démocratique
le centralisme démocratique suppose à la
fois la discussion et la discipline
c'est une sorte de mouvement de
va-et-vient la discussion démocratique
monte du bas vers le haut
la discipline redescend du haut vers le
bas la base fait connaître son point de
vue les décisions prises par le sommet
sont applicables par tous il n'est pas
possible aux militants de se regrouper
dans des tendances fraction le
centralisme implique l'unité de tous les
partis oui en effet c'est un boucher
mans la france 2 le copain mais a
complètement bloqué si l'on en croit
monsieur yves dusserre lui sert qui
sirotent reproche à la discussion de ne
pas bien fonctionner at-elle du parti
alors le premier reproche qu'il fait
c'est qu'il n'a pas ce mouvement de
va-et-vient que nous avons essayer de
figurer tout à l'heure pour lui
today to death en viendra aux tout vient
d'en haut et il emploie l'expression
nous avons vécu le temps des dix types
des grands parachutage ces parachutages
ce sont les mots d'ordre qui tombait du
ciel
et d'après lui les militants découvrait
que ces mots d'ordre étaient
radicalement différent des mots d'ordre
qu'ils avaient reçu au cours des
dernières années
et puis y trouve aussi que ça ne remonte
pas à ces deux là bas alors deuxième
point ça ne remonte pas assez de la base
qui bien que en principe le peuple est
souverain qui lie à discussion dans les
cellules mais la discussion ne remonte
pas plus haut dit il que le stade du
secrétariat des fédérations c'est à dire
au niveau départemental ou les
secrétaires de fédérations sont des
permanents
enfin dernière critique ça ne circule
pas horizontalement se dire que tout est
cloisonné oui il en fait l'expression
d'un cloisonnement verticale absolue
qu'il compare à une hiérarchie militaire
ce qui veut dire que en principe le
militant d'une cellule n'a aucun rapport
avec le militant d'une autre cellule qui
ne peut pas y avoir de rapport entre les
cellules
si ce n'est par le haut si ce n'est par
les délégués au comité de sexy alors
c'est un site une série d'articles trois
articles dont publie dans le monde très
dur oui et louis althusser en arrive à
cette conclusion l'organisation du parti
communiste est une machine à dominer à
contrôler et à manipuler les militants
et il en tire cette conclusion
c'est un fonctionnement à changer de
fond en comble et je crois
qu'effectivement vous disiez tout à
l'heure
jamais un communiste de l'intérieur ne
les critiquait aussi vivement le
fonctionnement de son parti et je crois
même que les grands exclus dans les
années passées n'étaient pas allés eux
mêmes ou six mois dans la critique dans
notre dernier journal nous aurons
l'occasion d'entendre jacques ferait
mentir et qui viennent quitté ses
fonctions de rédacteur en chef
chef de la revue action et qui donc
s'exprimant lui aussi sur les critiques
qu'il fait aux dirigeants du parti
communiste
politique toujours michel debré chez
valéry giscard d'estaing tout à l'heure
pas de déclarations de l'ancien premier
ministre à sa sortie de l'elysée
par ailleurs lancé le gaulliste claude
labbé a annoncé que le dossier sur la
taxe professionnelle serait ouvert à
l'assemblée avant que la fin de la
session sur l'amendement du gouvernement
et que le rpr lui demander un débat sur
la famille la sécu de sociale et la
participation
le drame italien maintenant rien de
nouveau aujourd'hui si ce n'est à
l'instant un appel de cours de valdaï
mot brigades rouges
et puis cette unanimité de tous les
partis pour refuser de céder aux
brigades rouges
et comme les conditions des terroristes
était elle même très dur on ne voit pas
comment la vie du président de la
démocratie chrétienne pourraient être
épargnés d'ailleurs l'homme pressent
l'issue fatale c'est très net dans une
lettre très bouleversante qu'il a
adressée au secrétaire général de son
parti et dans laquelle il demande aux
hommes politiques italiens de ne pas
assister à ses funérailles
il ne veut que ce vrai vert et c'est
dans ce contexte que de violents
incidents ont éclaté aujourd'hui la
suite d'une manifestation de l'extrême
gauche
les incidents entre manifestants et
forces de l'ordre à l'issue d'un meeting
je cite contre la répression victor rama
en ce jour où l'italie célèbre le 33ème
anniversaire de la libération
tout se passe comme si l'opinion
publique était résigné à prendre
l'exécution d'aldo moro
les centrales syndicales ont déposé des
gerbes de fleurs ce matin à l'endroit où
ont été assassinés les cinq gardes du
corps du président de la démocratie
chrétienne protestation contre le
terrorisme plutôt qu'un appel en faveur
d'aldo moro l'extrême gauche aussi a
voulu profiter de cet anniversaire la
libération pour manifester elle qui
après l'enlèvement d'aldo moro a rejeté
la moindre sympathie qu'elle pouvait
éprouver à l'égard des brigades rouges
on s'interrogeait d'ailleurs sur la
position de l'extrême gauche
la voici les brigades rouges ont le jeu
du régime
l'accord est parti communiste en créer
une homogénéité fausse homogénéité à la
base on aurait mis en jeu l'armée en
italie et vous savez que romain sacré
par année depuis huit ans l'armée était
pas présent dans la vie politique en
italie depuis quatre tentatives des
coups d'état était hors du jeu politique
aujourd'hui l'armée est à nouveau dans
le jeu politique
j'ai déclaré en faveur de la libération
d'al de mort ce nouvel garde pas
tellement nous sommes pour les droits à
la vie de toute façon nous croyons pas
qu'à un petit groupe peu et condamné à
mort quelqu'un a un nom du prolétariat
et non des révolutionnaires eux ils nous
représentent pas il nous reste plaisant
panique comme prolétaires ni comme
révolutionnaire donc on ne leur donne
pas le nom ne s'autorise pas à condamner
qu'ils se soient morts la répulsion à
l'égard des brigades rouges et général
unanimes quelles que soient les opinions
politiques répulsion mais aussi
résignation concrètement et puisque
personne n'accepte de négocier avec les
terroristes
il n'y a plus qu'à attendre le neuvième
message des brigades rouges
en attendant je voulais dix courtes van
damme socata générale des nations unies
s'est adressée aujourd'hui près
directement aux brigades rouges pour
leur demander de d'épargner la vie de
monsieur aldo moro et de le libérer
immédiatement c'est un appel qui est
radiodiffusé en ce moment sur les ondes
de la radio italienne quatrième
anniversaire aujourd'hui de la
révolution du 25 avril au portugal et à
cette occasion le conseil de la
révolution a mis en garde les portugais
contre les menaces qui selon lui pèse
sur la constitution et la démocratie et
ils y sont nombreuses les critiques
déversées sur le régime depuis la
révolution des oeillets sceptiques
numéro un nous l'avons dit hier une
économie complètement débridée avec la
palme du chômage et l'inflation et c'est
la raison pour laquelle ces registres et
a demandé au premier ministre mario
soares de s'expliquer la crise pensez
vous en avoir identifié les causes et
croyez-vous pouvoir la maîtriser
mais évidemment d'ailleurs la crise que
le portugal traverse n'est pas différent
la crise que tu as beaucoup d'autres
pays européens qui est due à une crise
économique internationale que vous sa
part est due à l'élévation du prix des
matières premières et du prix du pétrole
en septembre 75 vous disiez il faut
détruire le capitalisme
puis la social démocratie n'est pas
applicable au portugal alors est-ce que
vous avez aujourd'hui toujours
l'intention dé détruire le capitalisme
et comment définissez-vous l'actuel
système politique du organes pour le
moment nous sommes dans une phase
transitoire nous sommes jusqu'à 1980 en
association avec cbs c'est un pays
démocratique démocrate chrétien pour
consolider la démocratie les
institutions démocratiques et pour
récupérer l'économie du pays basque sans
une coop une économie l'état de
fonctionnement ne peut pas avoir
démocratie valable et pour moi la marche
vers le socialisme se fait à partir de
la démocratie d'une démocratie contenu
construisait pas vain sinon on tombe
dans une sorte capitalisme la façade
socialiste
qu' il y a beaucoup de régime qu'on
connaît et qui sont des régimes
d'oppression
est ce que monsieur le premier ministre
vous un sentiment que la démocratie est
solidement installé dans votre pays ou
coup d'état est encore possible mais je
pense que il y à des forces anti
démocratiques est assez vive l'effort
dans mon pays je ne pense pas qu'ils ont
qu'ils vont y oscille là dessus je suis
optimiste mais je pense qu'il faut te
faut lutter contre les anti démocrates
qui veulent un retour un arriéré toulon
pas ses intérêts alors 25 avril
ce retour est impossible ne peut plus
particulier ne permit pas parce que
c'est un peuple épris de liberté
il ne veut pas faire le tour au facisme
il ya une idylle i chap p caloni dj ce
n'est pas n'importe qui c'est le vice
ministre soviétique des affaires
étrangères c'est l'homme qui négociaient
jusqu'à l'or avec la chine sur les
problèmes des frontières des deux pays
mais cela fait quatorze mois que les
négociations étaient rompues entre les
débits l'urss ne produira pas la bombe à
neutrons tant que les états unis
soutiendront de le faire via de dire
aujourd'hui il donne une brejnev
c'est la première vraie réponse à la
décision de jimmy carter d'ajourner la
production de cette bombe à neutrons les
livres jeunesse mais pas pour autant
très tendre avec le président américain
cette décision est une demi mesure at il
dit première vraie réflexion de l'église
française la suite de la proposition de
loi du sénateur caillavet visant à
supprimer ce qu'on l'appelle
l'acharnement thérapeutique c'est à dire
la survie parfois artificielles de
certains malades
c'est monseigneur etchegaray le
président de la conférence épiscopale
qui prend position dans une réflexion
qu'il va publier samedi dans son
bulletin diocésain
il n'est par contre la proposition qu'il
y avait eu seulement deux simplement si
l'on peut régler par une loi un problème
complexe comme tous les problèmes
humains sur tout ce qui touche la vie et
puis il ne faudrait pas continue
l'archevêque de marseille ne faudrait
pas que la réflexion se limite à
l'euthanasie passive ou l'euthanasie
active
il faut promouvoir l'humanisation des
hôpitaux devenus souvent un monde de
froid de solitude pour reprendre
l'expression
de marseille une prise de position à
suivre l'environnement ne doit plus être
un rattrapage mais un préalable a dit
michel d'ornano invité aujourd'hui de
l'association des journalistes de
l'environnement
le ministre a par ailleurs annoncé la
mise en place d'un remorqueur de 16000
chevreau prochainement à brest pour
éviter que se reproduisent des
catastrophes du type de l'amoco cadiz et
son collègue jean pierre soisson a
annoncé aujourd'hui à roye que son
ministère organisera une campagne de
promotion touristique de la bretagne
parce que là bas les plages se nettoie
très très vite
deux rendez vous demain soir sur antenne
2 à 22h15 le magazine dont je vous ai
déjà parlé quelle france consacré aux
pyrénées atlantiques
et puis juste avant un événement pour
tous les sportifs le match aller de la
finale de la coupe de l'uefa bastia
eindhoven un événement retransmis donc
par intel 2 à 20h30 tout de suite après
le journal est donc bernard père nous
présente les ingrédients à bastia c'est
l'euphorie qui règne mais aussi un
certain énervement à mesure que l'heure
h approche les ouvriers travaillent
d'arrache-pied pour installer les 12 100
places supplémentaires
mais combien seront ils à avoir la
chance d'assister à cette finale bien
difficile à dire peut-être peut-être à
l'entracte jettera ses habitants 5000 de
plus qui attendent heures auront près
certains parlent même de 20000 malgré
des prix allant de 130 à 360 francs
mais disputer une finale de coupe
d'europe dans ce stade semble être une
gageure
les dirigeants de bastia qui souhaitait
jouer à paris ou marseille ont dû
reculer devant les pressions voire les
menaces
si l'équipe de bastia est un stade
européen
elle ne doit quand même à ses supporters
puisqu'il ya quand même une motivation
et a quand même un dynamisme qui le
connais on aurait dû le constater
évidemment les commerçants et les
ateliers sont intéressés au premier chef
qu'à l'économie locale
c'est quand même important à l'oublier
pack pour le match de bastia cullin il
ya eu plus de chance
un million d'anciens verts ne changeait
de ré banques or je considère que sol
était gelé des injustices que de faire
le match à bastia
seul souci pour les supporters bastiais
les blessures de papier rec le coude
pour l'un la cuisse pour l'autre mais
finalement ils pourront quand même jouer
demain soir ce qui vous arrive
être en finale de foncia sort de huit
saisons maintenant nouvelle saison ne
pensait pas encore peut-être je ne
réalise pas encore game en fait je crois
que c'est surtout pour les supporters je
crois que ça et toute la corse voit la
vie en bleu et en blanc
en fait on ne pense qu'à cette finale
par exemple les postillons changer les
horaires de levée du courrier
le bateau bastia marseille partira plus
tard que prévu vers minuit
bref en un mot c'est l'événement
événement aussi sur cette chaîne donc
demain à 20h30 j'apprends l'instant le
décès de la doyenne des français elle
avait 112 ans s appeler la chine du m
elle est morte à son domicile de vatine
ide en ordre dans le domaine de
l'insolite ce soir la mort dans la
misère du chauffeur d'al capone qui
s'était retiré dans sa sicile natale et
qui meurt complètement oublié de la
mafia et puis la condamnation du
gouvernement britannique par la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme qui a
donc donné raison à ce jeune homme qui
se plaignait d'avoir reçu trois coups de
canne sur les fesses si vous avez
regardé le journal samedi soir savait
que ce jeune homme est originaire de
l'île de man en mer d'irlande et que là
bas les châtiments corporels sont encore
de rigueur et bien la cour de strasbourg
a dit que cela n'était plus possible les
autorités de l'île de man ont manifesté
aujourd'hui leur grande déception devant
ce jugement
je vous propose de terminer ce journal
en images avec en avant première pour
antenne de quelques unes des nouvelles
techniques d'animation à hollywood et
techniques que vous pourrez découvrir à
partir de demain dans deux cinémas
parisiens et vallet loire grâce à
georges bégoux les réalisateurs
américains n'ont pas hésité à employer
des procédés réservé jusqu'à présent aux
jeux dans regardez bien
après l'âge d'or des grandes usines de
dessins animés dont l'entreprise walt
disney constitue le plus beau fleuron
une nouvelle génération de réalisateurs
de dessin et l'animation utilisent
aujourd'hui à hollywood des techniques
apparemment enfantine tels que la
pixilation prise de vue image par image
dans un univers à trois dimensions peut
parvenir à ce résultat avec une super 8
mai accrochez vous bien car ce sont de
vrais professionnels de l'animation
dirigé par même ville brent johnson qui
vous font une démonstration de course de
moto très particulière
et
pour cette séquence de 40 secondes des
heures et des heures de tournage ont été
nécessaires
encore un jeu de patience empruntés aux
enfants par will vinton qui a amené la
pâte à modeler à l'âge adulte
il a créé le premier studio au monde de
pâte à modeler à limay image par image
l'objectif de la caméra
tiens voilà le metteur en scène
alors je finis cette prise de vue encore
quelques planches et les analyses
d'urines robert soir petits spécialistes
les trucages en animation dans les
superproductions comme rencontre du
troisième type mène une carrière
parallèle en produisant des films
personnels entièrement dessinée
directement sur la pellicule
quand on sait qu'il faut 24 images pour
une seconde de projection
e
la libye
la météo pour demain est pessimiste elle
prévoit un temps maussade sur la plus
grande partie du pays ciel couvert avec
des pluies et des averses parfois
orageuses dans le midi l'est et le
nord-est les températures ne bougeront
guerre c'est gérard holtz qui vous
présentera la dernière édition du
journal aux alentours de 23h30 c'est à
dire après les dossiers de l'écran merci
nous avoir suivis bonne soirée à tous et
j'espère à demain